it's that time again it's time for CBS
morning's deals this week we have three
items designed with your self-care in
mind and they just might become
Essentials in your everyday life and
they're all at exclusive low prices to
start shopping go ahead scan that QR
code on your screen right now go ahead
and do it or you can visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle host Gail bass is joining us
once again yeah what's up guys oh you're
gonna love this one this is the Spina
you know why you're gonna love the spine
yeah you can take a seat because the
Spina never says honey I'm too tired to
feed your back you'll be able to get
into that appointment without having to
wait a week to get a massage do you feel
something neat yeah feel it in my neck
and my back yeah my bum yes there's
kneading there's heat and there's
vibration in this thing and it's
wonderful for you if it's wonderful
because look at this you don't have to
put it in a tall sitting chair I thought
you did you could put it in a low chair
you could put it on your couch it is a
great thing to have
it's a strong massage this isn't like a
little light vibration right and this is
adjustable it'll adjust to your neck to
need where you need it to need so if you
work out a lot because he's been an
athlete you like to hike this is the
thing you get on or if you're working
and you need a break or and you need
some heat vibration or a kneading back
this is a great product for you and I
love the price point on this because we
have it for 220 off so we have it for
179.99
you know and I like how you put athlete
in the past tense grenade there it has
been not currently there you go just get
comfortable that's our next item oh
really oh yeah a little something in
there keep things cold for you okay it's
a water bottle yeah this is do we need
another water bottle yes you do okay
I'll tell you why because you and I both
like to hike this is by the Gronkowski
brothers and they are athletes yeah and
they like to get in the car and not have
water that's 120 degrees when you forget
your water bottle in the car like I do I
live in the desert it happens to me all
the time time I put ice in mine to test
it out 24 hours later there was still
ice and cold water in this bottle and
what I like about it too is this is
removable so when you take this off it's
easy to clean they give you more than
one and I love this because it keeps it
so cold for so long so if it rolls under
the seat like it happens for moms and
busy dads this is a great product for
you and you have to remember to hydrate
and what also is great it comes with 20
different colors so if you don't like
those on there go on the website you're
going to find something you're going to
love clean out the alcohol yeah I mean
water yes this is the ice Shaker and we
have it for 40 off for 20.79.
it can keep things hot too okay and now
people can have some decisions to make
because you've got the back massager
there but we've got a neck massager yeah
here from re-athlete this is called NECA
I love the NECA because it has heat and
kneading and you can use this because
you're jealous right now I see Nate
looking at me with this you know how you
put your laptop on the Riser well you
put this on while you you're typing
standing up and you can use this this is
for people
if my door is shut you know what's going
on you can put it you could you can work
and use that that's perfect for a nurse
can you turn it on oh yeah just hold
this right here
oh wow yeah let's move it right there
you're moving move it right there and
then you know pretend like you're typing
you work while you're doing that you can
work while you're doing that and it has
heat too yeah so you know because I like
to put warm stuff on all right I don't
have to hold my arms up no you don't
think I like massages but I do I am very
massages I go to the spot nope I like
massages this is like getting the
pedicure without the pedicure did we get
a price on this one so yeah this one is
100 off 100 off yeah it's it's 99 this
is a great stocking stuffer for a nurse
wow or a teacher or anybody who has to
stand up a lot or who has neck trouble
or spends all day looking at their phone
like this well there's that that's
everyone that's everyone that's everyone
oh hey hey I I see why you guys like it
that's what I'm talking
to the best get it on the phone come on
so much we appreciate it yes I'll take
this hotel and of course and of course
we partner with all of these brands so
you can go out there I'm knocking my
glasses off right now and partner with
all these companies for these incredible
deals and you can purchase anything that
you saw scan the QR code on your screen
right now you can also visit
cbsdeals.com to get all of these cool
products and more
I'm trying to decide what this is doing
for me though it's doing everything Gail
we'll be right back
[Music]